U.S and South Korean warplanes carrying
out a highly visible response to the
latest missile launch by North Korea
South Korea's defense Ministry said the
drills headed by nuclear-capable
American B-1 bombers affirmed the United
States commitment to the extended
deterrence of its nuclear weapons the
U.S and Japan held a similar separate
exercise over Waters off Japan's West
Coast where the missile came down on
Saturday
North Korea's State media agency says
Crews were given no early warning ahead
of the order to launch the hwasong 15
intercontinental ballistic missile proof
it says a capability to deliver a quote
fatal nuclear counter-attack
these images were released on Sunday
along with a statement from the sister
of North Korea's leader Kim Jong-un Kim
Yoo Jung said Pyongyang would watch
every enemy movement and counteract
every hostile action North Korea is not
happy with the ramping up of uh military
exercises between the U.S and South
Korea which will take place in March
there's also a tabletop exercise that
will look at nuclear scenarios that will
happen between the U.S and South Korea
next week and I think North Korea is
sending a message that it is unhappy
with that and it will uh Fight Fire with
Fire
well this launch still took some hours
between order and ignition North Korea
continues to work on a solid fuel rocket
that takes less time to prepare years of
diplomacy sanctions and international
censure have done little to slow its
progress Harry Fawcett Al Jazeera